(slogans des manifestants)
- "Liberté, nous voulons
la liberté", scandent
des résidents de Shanghai
sortis pour une vigile
à la chandelle qui s'est
transformée en manifestation.
Rassemblés sur la rue
qui porte le nom d'Urumqi,
les manifestants ont fini
par être dispersés par
la police avant l'aube.
Il y a quelques jours,
l'intervention des services
d'incendie de la capitale
du Xinjiang auraient
été ralentis à cau
des restrictions sanitaires
et dix personnes sont mortes.
(slogans des manifestants)
Ce triste événement a soulevé
un mouvement populaire contre
les mesures draconiennes pour
contrôler la pandémie en Chine,
autant à Urumqi qu'ailleurs
au pays. Mais les rassemblements
ont pris une autre tournure
dans les dernières heures.
(slogans des manifestants)
La foule s'est mise à réclamer
la démission du président.
Une revendication extrêmement
inhabituelle; les Chinois
sont rarement dissidents
avec le régime de Pékin.CeCeCeCs
durant la nuit.
(exclamations de colère)
Rien pour découragerles manifes
qui sont toujours là.
Et certains n'ont pas peur
de se faire arrêter, comme cet
homme qui brandit des fleurs,
un symbole de protestation.
La foule, impuissante,
ne peut que crier et filmer les
actions des forces de l'ordre.
Le mot t t t étudiant emboîte
le pas, ici, à la prestigieuse
Université Tsinghua, à Pékin.
Brandissant des feuilles
bl, , , , symbole contre
la censure, les étudiants
ont également démontré leur
hostilité envers le président
et le régime en place.
(chant des manifestants)
Les rues de la capitale chinoise
sont aussi devenues
des lieux d'attroupement
pour les citoyens, qui tiennent
bien haut des feuilles blanches.
La force du nombre aide
peut-être à faire sortir
cette colère qui gronde au sei
de la population chinoise et qui
a émergé soudainement avec les
victimes de l'incendie d'Urumqi,
Radio-Can